I've founded a charity for children in
Wharton in war zones in refugee camps
I'm intrigued I also am politically
active to try and stop the circumstances
that put them in that place and in the
first place I'm intrigued what the jab
jab jab right hook principles that could
be applied with him that paradigm would
be what the best channels would be in
your view and had have had a best user
to me I you've noticed that suddenly I
said nonprofits a couple times right
because I have a lot of passion for to
some of the board of pencils of promise
which is an organization that builds
schools in in the third-world countries
and I've been so happy that I've been
able to bring my expertise to that
organization because we're doing so much
better on social network donations there
is no but as bad as companies are as bad
as big companies are in on social
networks only throwing right hooks even
worse are charities every [ __ ] tweet
is donate this for every dollar you
retweet this that I can review can you
retweet this every [ __ ] minute 40
times a day I have been approached by a
non-profit many times this week to
retweet for a campaign
none of which even said hello to me
before asking me right so like you know
it's it's absurd to me the jab - jab
right hook in an NGO world is the best
you know why the jabs are the height of
emotion you want to put out pictures of
that scenario as jabs guess what you
give me enough of those pictures enough
people share them I see that you're
gonna be able to land your right hook on
me you just asked me for money with one
picture I mean the NGO space is the
worst they are they they're just so
stuck in asking for money and they need
to romance their donators